all the problems we've been dealing with
so far have had have essentially been
happening in one dimension you could go
forward or back so you could go forward
or back or right or left or you could go
up or down what I want to start to talk
about in this video is what happens when
we extend that to two dimensions or we
can even just extend what we're doing
this video to three or four really an
arbitrary number of dimensions although
if you're dealing with classical
mechanics you normally don't have to go
more than three dimensions and if you're
going to deal with more than one
dimension especially in two dimensions
we're also going to be dealing with
two-dimensional vectors and I just want
to make sure through this video that we
understand at least the basics of two
dimensional vectors remember a vector or
something that has both magnitude and
direction so the first thing I want to
do is just give you a visual
understanding of how vectors in two
dimensions would add so let's say I have
a vector right here that is vector a so
once again its magnitude is specified by
the length of this arrow and it's
Direction is specified by the direction
of the arrow so it's going in that
direction now let's say I have another
vector let's call it vector V let's call
it vector B it looks like this and what
I want to do in this video is think
about what happens when I add vector a
to vector B so there's a couple things
to think about when you visually depict
vectors the important thing is for
example for vector a that you get the
length right and you get the direction
right where you actually draw it doesn't
matter so this could be vector a this
could also be vector a notice it has the
same length and it has the same
direction this is also vector a I could
draw a vector a up here it does not
matter I could draw the vector a up
there I could draw a vector V I could
draw a vector B over here it's still
vector B it still has the same magnitude
and the direction notice we're not
saying that its tail has to start at the
same place that vector a's tail starts
at i could draw a vector b over here so
i can i can always have the same vector
but i can shift it around so i could
move it up there as long as it has the
same magnitude the same length and the
same direction and the whole reason I'm
doing that is because the way to
visually add vector
if I wanted to add vector a if I wanted
to add vector A plus vector B plus
vector B and I'll show you how to do it
more analytically in a future video
I can literally draw a vector a I draw a
vector a so that's vector a right over
there and then I can draw a vector B but
I put the tail of vector B to the head
of vector a so I shift vector B over so
its tail is right at the head of vector
a and then vector B would look something
like this it would look something like
this and then if you go from the tail of
a all the way to the head of B all the
way to the head of B and you call that
vector C and you call that vector C that
is the sum of a and B that is the sum of
a and B and it shouldn't make sense if
you think about it if these were let's
say these were displacement vectors so a
shows that you're being displaced this
much in this direction B shows that
you're being displaced this much in this
direction so the length of B in that
direction and I were to say you have a
displacement of a and then you have a
displacement of B what is your total
displacement so you would have had to be
I get shifted this far in this direction
and then you would be shifted this far
in this direction so you the net amount
that you've been shifted is this far in
that direction so that's why this would
be the sum of those now we can use that
same idea to break down any vector in
two dimensions into its we could say
into its components and I'll give you a
better sense of what that means in a
second so if I have vector a let me pick
a new letter let's call let's call this
let's call this vector vector X let's
call this vector X I can say that vector
X is going to be the sum of this is
going to be the sum of this vector right
here in green and this vector right here
in red notice if I take if I X starts at
the tail of the green vector and goes
all the way to the head of the magenta
of a correct vector and the magenta
vector starts at the head of the green
and then and then finishes I guess well
where it finishes is where vector X
finishes and the reason why I do this
and you know this hopefully from this
comp explanation right here says okay
look vector Gris the green vector plus
the magenta vector gives us this X
vector that should make sense I put the
I put the head of the green vector to
the tail of this magenta vector right
over here but the whole reason why I did
this is if I can express X as the sum of
these two vectors it then breaks down X
into its vertical component and its
horizontal component so I could call
this I could call this the I could call
this the horizontal component or I
should say the vertical component X
vertical and then I could call this over
here I could call this over here the X
horizontal or another way I could draw
it I could shift this X vertical over
remember it doesn't matter where I draw
it as long as it's the same magnitude
and direction and I could draw it like
this X vertical and so what you see is
is that you can express this vector X
you can express this vector X let me do
the same colors you can express this
vector X as the sum of its horizontal
and its vertical components as the sum
of its horizontal and its vertical
components now we're going to see over
and over again that this is super this
is super powerful because what it can do
is it can turn a two-dimensional problem
into two separate one-dimensional
problems one acting in a horizontal
direction one acting in a vertical
direction now let's do it a little bit
more mathematical I've just been telling
you about length and all of that but
let's actually break down let me just
show you what this means to break down
the components of a vector so let's say
let's say that I have a vector that
looks like this let me do my best to so
let's say I have a vector that looks
like this its length is 5 so let me call
this vector a and I will say so vector
A's length is equal to 5 and let's say
that its direction we're going to give
it we're going to give us direction by
the angle between the direction it's
pointing it
and the positive x-axis so maybe I'll
draw some an axis over here so let's say
that this right over here is the
positive y-axis going in the vertical
direction this right over here is the
positive x-axis going in the horizontal
direction and to specify this vectors
direction I will give this angle right
over here and I'm going to give a very
peculiar anger but angle but I picked
this for specific reasons just so things
work out neatly in the end and I'm going
to give it in degrees it's thirty six
point eight six nine nine degrees so I'm
picking that particular number for a
particular reason and what I want to do
is I want to figure out this vectors
horizontal and vertical component so I
want to break it down into something
that's going straight up or down and
something that's going straight right or
left so how do I do this well one I
could just draw them visually see what
they look like so it's vertical
component would look like this so let me
it's it would start it would its
vertical component would look like this
and it's horizontal component would look
like this its horizontal component would
look like this the horizontal component
the way I drew it would start where
vector a starts and go as far in the X
direction as vector a is a tip but only
in the X direction and then you need it
to get back to the head of vector a you
need to have its vertical component and
we can sometimes call this we could call
the vertical component over here a sub y
just so that it's moving in the Y
direction and we could call this
horizontal component a a sub X and what
I want to do is I want to figure out the
magnitude of a sub y and a sub X so how
do we do that well the way we drew this
I've essentially set up a right triangle
for us this is a right triangle we know
the length of this triangle the length
of or the length of this side or the
length of the hypotenuse that's going to
be the magnitude of vector a and so the
magnitude of vector a is equal to five
we already knew that up here so how do
we figure out these sides well we could
use a little bit of basic trigonometry
if we know the angle and we know the
hypotenuse how do we figure out the
opposite side to the angle so this right
here
right here is the opposite side to the
angle and if we forgot some of our basic
trigonometry we can relearn it right now
so uh so katoa sine is opposite over
hypotenuse cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse tangent is opposite over
adjacent so we we have the angle we want
the opposite and we have the hypotenuse
so we could say we could say that the
sine the sign of our angle the sine of
thirty six point eight nine nine degrees
is going to be equal to the opposite
over the hypotenuse the opposite side of
the angle is our what is the magnitude
of our Y component is going to be equal
to the magnitude of our Y component the
magnitude of our Y component over the
magnitude of the hypotenuse over this
length over here which we know is going
to be equal to five or if you multiply
both sides by 5 you get 5 sine of thirty
six point eight nine nine degrees is
equal to the magnitude is equal to the
vertical component the magnitude of the
vertical component of our vector a now
before I take out the calculator and
figure out what this is let me do the
same thing for the for the horizontal
component over here we know this side is
adjacent to the angle and we know the
hypotenuse and so cosine deals with
adjacent and hypotenuse so we know that
the cosine of thirty six point eight
nine nine degrees is equal to cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse is equal to the
magnitude of our X of our X component
over the hypotenuse the hypotenuse here
has or the magnitude of the hypotenuse I
should say which has a length of five
once again we multiply both sides by
five and we get five times the cosine of
thirty six point eight nine nine degrees
is equal to the magnitude of our X of
our X component so let's figure out what
these are let me get the calculator out
let me get the let me get my trusty
ti-85 out one
make sure it's in degree mode so let me
check yep we're in degree mode right
over there I want to make sure we're not
in Radian mode now let's exit that and
we have the vertical component is equal
to five times the sine the sine of
thirty six point eight nine nine degrees
which is if we round it right at about
three so this is equal to so the
magnitude of our vertical component is
equal to three is equal to three and
then let's do the same thing for our
horizontal component for our horizontal
component so now we have five times five
times the cosine of thirty six point
eight nine nine degrees is if we once
again if we round it to I guess our
hundreds place we get it to being four
so we get it to being four so we see
here is a situation where we have this
is this is a classic three four five
Pythagorean triangle the magnitude of
our horizontal component is for the
magnitude of our vertical component the
vadik the magnitude of our vertical
component right over here is equal to
three and once again you might say Sal
you know why why are we going through
all this trouble and we'll see in the
next videos if we say something has a
velocity in this direction of five
meters per second we can actually say
that we can break that down into two
component velocities we can say that
that's going in the upwards direction at
three meters per second and it's also
going to the right in the horizontal
direction at four meters per second and
it allows us to break up the problem
into two simpler problems into two
one-dimensional problems instead of a
bigger two-dimensional one